brasil registra los peores datos desde
el inicio de la pandemia en la última
semana se ha registrado una media diaria
de 1.274 muertos además en el estado de
sampaolo cada dos minutos hay una
solicitud de ingreso hospitalario por
esta razón para evitar el temido colapso
de los hospitales su autoría el
gobernador de san paolo ha anunciado hoy
nuevas medidas restrictivas a partir del
próximo sábado y hasta el 19 de marzo
permanecerán cerradas las tiendas los
restaurantes y en los gimnasios y sólo
funcionarán los servicios esenciales
además quedarán abiertas las escuelas y
los lugares de culto mañana también el
alcalde de río de janeiro anunciará
nuevas restricciones al movimiento de
los ciudadanos mientras tanto algunos de
los mayores expertos sanitarios del país
recomiendan un lock down de tres semanas
para el presidente y jair bolsonaro no
quiere saber de este lock down ayer
cuando el país ha alcanzado su récord
histórico con más de 1.700 muertes en un
solo día bolsonaro
a los medios de comunicación de querer
sembrar el pánico recordó de nuevo que
la economía no puede parar y dijo que él
no tiene la culpa de tantos muertos hay
que recordar que brasil se está
acercando al récord de 260 mil muertes y
la situación en las próximas dos semanas
puede empeorar